I just wasn't prepared for a
relationship like I had no idea how much
you had to care
it is a staggering amount of care
involved in a relationship but my girl
cares so much about me but in such a
wide range and this is tough for dudes
I don't think genetically I'm capable of
caring about this I care about my girl
deeply from my soul I love her but I
will never care about you know I'm never
gonna care about like her day it's a day
bro you have literally had thousands of
these I gotta care about this you got
another one coming at eight hours kind
of life is that what's even worse my
girl cares about my day I don't care
about my day every time I walk through
the door babe how was your day
over
want me to do this again I didn't like
in the first time I just do it so we can
pay bills huh and I got a care man I'm
telling you I gotta care about her day
and I got to pretend everyday it's not
the same story in a different retail
setting she comes in all in a huff oh my
god babe you will not believe what just
happened to me I try to go to Macy's to
return the sweater in this [ __ ] at
customer service wouldn't let me take it
back talking about you need a receipt
I'm sorry babe do you even care about
that no I didn't know that was it that's
the end of the story that's not even a
climax that's just how the store works
you don't have a receipt you go home
but I want to be a great husband don't
get it twisted I want to be a great
husband so I have had to practice caring
because my girl needs me to hear that
story and emotionally connect I have to
hear that story and find a way to go
what up or this receipt neatness [ __ ]
I mean honestly baby how dare this woman
follow store policy this is an outrage
you want me to call somebody I always
got to pretend I'm gonna call somebody
whoa can I call with this story I'm just
gonna hit up Macy's and be like hey guys
honestly great work trying to do that in
four years
actually you guys training
[Music]